taraji P Hinson shares what shocked her  most about Brad Pitt something is very  interesting proud mary actress appeared  on Thursdays watch what happens live  with Andy Cohen when a caller asked her  to share the most surprising thing she  learned about Pitt after working  together on 2008 the Curious Case of  Benjamin Button found out too earthy is  I mean he is so down to earth  taraji received an Oscar nomination for  her performance portraying Pitt's mother  in the film she has nothing but  admiration for her co-star something is  very interesting you know the paparazzi  they chased him and he and Kate like  crazy meanwhile I'm in the car like  there I go  anyway but he he almost looked as if why  are they chasing me why don't they want  pictures of me that's how humble he is  he would be you get thrown like like  what why are they here you know he's a  great guy good guy not caring very  caring guy  [Music]  you